tamo gun G it's Call of Duty's
Tamagotchi pets that happened to be
really bloodthirsty you may be on the
fence if you want to buy one or not so
here's what you should know about them
first off how to get one for now you'll
have to buy your demanding friend they
can be purchased at the in-game store as
part of a bundle that runs around a
thousand Cod points or something like
ten dollars you equip it by tapping over
to the weapons menu and then navigating
down to watch select it's not
immediately clear what you're looking at
or how Tama gun G's work so let's break
it down for you
similar to Tamagotchi you'll start with
an egg and after a round or two a small
head will emerge there our child teen
and adult stages also multiple pets can
appear if you want to know how your
current pet is feeling look to the right
where there are four indicators these
are hungry dirty unruly and sleepy when
these moves are active you need to go
play according to the blog post quote
kills objective scoring kill streaks and
wins all contribute towards a positive
mood while playing poorly will cause
your pets health to decline that means
that if you fail to play enough Call of
Duty your pet can die when your pet
doesn't have a mood indicator it means
everything is great and you can tell
yourself you got this parenting thing
down all right so how do you figure out
what your pet likes and what to feed it
below your animal is a progress bar that
indicates a bonus score the higher that
score the faster your pet will evolve
there are several different types of
pets and each one has a different way to
fill the bonus meter some require quote
captures killstreaks objective plants or
top three wins you'll have to experiment
to find out which one your Tamagotchi
likes this judgemental little fella here
liked objective caps there also appears
to be two States for example your pet
can be crying while you're losing a
match but overall happy in the main menu
and that brings us to a very fundamental
question how do you see your pet so
there are two main ways to keep track of
the Tamagotchi while in a match the
first way is to glance at your watch you
can set this up by going to your
barracks menu identity section then
gestures and sprays and make sure you
have the standard check watch remote
equipped this allows you to quickly
glance at your watch in-game in our
opinion it's a little bit too fast and
there's a better way to do it
the other method takes some
experimentation and requires you to find
the right weapon your operator will grip
certain guns towards the front with
their watch hands may
the Tommy Gunn G visible at all times we
found the assault rifle category is
particularly good for this just make
sure you don't add on an underbarrel
attachment that lowers your operators
grip below the screen alright go have
fun let us know in the comments below if
you purchased a tommy gun G and what
you're feeding that little guy stick to
GameSpot for more coverage of call of
duty modern warfare
hopefully battle royale and thanks for
watching Tom again G
[Music]